good morning Hank it's Tuesday we have a
puppy his name is potato he is the
greatest he's such a good boy he's such
a good puppy so Hank even though potato
is only 5 months old he already does a
lot of work including the work of
getting a Pokeball and the critical work
of making sure that if anybody leaves
granola on the kitchen table he he eats
it we call him potato because the person
we got him from does not speak English
as her first language and when she first
showed us the puppy she said look at him
he just little potato you touch his ears
potato you snuggle with him potato and
the kids were immediately like potato
potato his name is potato and we were
like no we need to give him a proper
Regal name like the dread pirate
Fireball Wilson Roberts and they said
potato potato his name is potato and
they won but it is true he is little
potato he's good at snuggling he's good
at sitting he's very good at pooping he
does it all day outside inside anywhere
he's just a great dog I know everybody
body thinks their dog is great but
potato is frankly greater because our
kids have serious lung and Allergy
issues potato was one of the only dogs
that would work for our family and boy
does he work he's just a joy to go on
walks with and he's a great cuddler he's
a kind of dog called a loto Roman YOLO
which I think you're supposed to say
with an Italian accent but I can only
say it with a Southern accent for some
reason as he grows out of his puppy coat
he'll actually be less white and gray
and more Brown and so in addition to
being potato he will resemble potato all
right some questions people have asked
us is it cannibalism for potato to eat
potatoes no just as it is not
cannibalism for people named venison to
eat deer meat not sure why I picked that
particular example but I bet there's
somebody named venison as it happens
potato is not a huge fan of potatoes
which is surprising because he'll eat
anything he'll eat small rocks and grass
and this one kind of moss he ate a 128
gab memory card and I would get mad at
him but I will remind you that like 6
years ago I also ate a 128 GB memory
card so I know I know what it's like I
mean to be fair a memory card and a
pretzel Chip have almost the exact same
thickness and overall weight does potato
know he has a tail uh seemingly no every
time potato sees his tail in his
peripheral vision he is astonished
thrilled and slightly terrified can he
do the format yeah so it's really hard
being a dog and I really struggle with
it sometimes but hope is still the
correct response to the miracle of dog
Consciousness does potato know his name
potato I don't know it's it's arguable
has potato been properly educated about
tuberculosis so listen potato dogs
actually can get tuberculosis but it's
quite rare so I don't think it's
something you in particular need to
worry about okay but it is the world's
deadliest infectious disease among
humans and the thing you need to know
about a potato is that it's curable okay
so we don't have to accept the world
that we're choosing right now here's a
treat thank you for listening to my TED
Talk does he like socks potato look what
I have it's a Hank Green cancer sock
potato
come oh oh Hank potato and I will see
you on Friday